let let me just ask you a
question this is nothing new right
you've heard about all these stories
that uh that Robert Muse and David wood
have told you've seen them on ABC and
NBC and CBS
right you've seen them on Fox all over
the place
right what a funny thing isn't that odd
and actually it's not odd at all
obviously we all know that in the United
States right now the mainstream media
for whatever reason is completely
complicit with the Sharia initiatives
that are trying to advance Islamic law
and to assert the principle that
wherever Islamic law and American law
conflict it's American law that has to
give way in Islamic law it is forbidden
for non-muslims to prosze among Muslims
it's not forbidden in the United States
for Christians to preach Christianity so
what Dearborn was doing to David wood
and Nabil kesi and the others was
enforcing Islamic law upon them now this
should have been front page Banner
headlines in the New York Times and the
Detroit Free Press and everywhere else
this should have been first lead story
all week on all the top news channels
because this is a story about our
fundamental rights and instead if they
reported at all if it if it got into the
Free Press at all you can be sure it was
about
islamophobia and it was about hate
speech well you saw nail you saw the
video he wasn't preaching hate and
neither are we we are preaching the
defense of our rights we are preaching
freedom and equality of Rights for all
people there's nothing hateful about
saying we want everybody to be subject
to the same law and the same
responsibilities and everyone have the
same rights under the law oh what how
hateful but
anyway the thing is the media we know is
nowhere the media as Pamela has dubbed
it is the en media is on the other side
as a matter of fact we have to leave the
country to find anyone with a prominent
Voice who has the courage to speak about
these things honestly and I'm very happy
to say he's with us here now y Michael
Corin is the host of a television show
on the excellent sun TV network in
Canada he is one of the very few people
in the media who has the courage to take
on these issues to discuss them fully
and honestly without the C without the
obfuscation without the denial and
without the propaganda that the
mainstream media steadily subjects us to
when it comes to issues of how Islamic
law is threatening our freedoms and so
it is with great pleasure and honor I
introduce to you Michael
Corin thank
you thank you that was very nice bit
more if you like I'm fine with
that thank you for uh inviting me to
your lovely little
country as an Englishman I've always
wanted to say that to Americans and as a
Canadian I
can I just explain a little bit about my
background because now by the way I have
to establish that you can understand me
because I speak English
properly and you're American so uh I'm
from England originally I've been in
Canada half my life I was a journalist
in the UK and uh the only reason I ended
up in Canada is because golly back in
1986 I was at the University of Tana as
they call it I was invited over to give
a lecture and uh at the party boring
conference but at a party at the end of
the conference is this very beautiful
woman came up to me and she she must
have been drunk she said she said you're
amazing you're amazing and thinking this
may never happen again I married
her and I was quite right cuz it hasn't
happened ever again so that is how I I I
got to can but you know I grew up in
Britain in a little town called ilford
which is where London and Essex meet
there's nothing ilford ilford Anonymous
but I grew up I went to the local state
school it was very nice univ of Britain
we had educ free education and health
care and the Queen and Dentistry no not
the
last it was a lovely way to grow up with
the great benefits of of of Britain in
in the 1960s and and 1970s there was a
young man who grew up uh three streets
away from me uh but he my father drove a
cab drove a cab those black cabs in
England we weren't particularly wealthy
uh he he did have money this young man
who grew up just three streets away from
me so he went to the local private
school his parents could afford
that he had the best of everything
Britain could give a as as North America
gives tolerance and pluralism and
respect no I'm serious about that no I'm
not this is not a joke uh We Are The
postchristian World the world
established on Christianity is a light
unto the rest of the universe Britain
North America Australia New
Zealand Europe what do these all have in
common pragmatism liberalism so no no
Christianity but anyway he he grew up
with all the benefits of the United
Kingdom he went on after his private
education to be a member of a gang who
kidnapped Danny Pearl and cut his head
off not of course before they had made
him confess and admit to being a
Jew and then they held his severed head
up to the camera as a warning to
others I'm sure the oppression and the
Injustice and the poverty that young man
had grown up in turned him into a
murderer not his
religion
anyway let me talk to you a little about
what goes on in Canada now I feel almost
embarrassed to be here what I've heard
here I mean what can I say I thought I
knew about what Islamic radicalism
Sharia law the strict interpretation of
the Muslim faith led to but what I what
I've heard here I thought Canada was in
bad shape what happened especially in
that in that discussion of the Christian
Gospel is beyond belief a young woman I
don't know if she's in the room now a
young woman from the Arab American uh
news station said to me outside and she
was very nervous and I felt for her she
she was shaking she said do you think
dear born is the right place for this
conference I said I'm not really sure
let me change that answer yes it is yes
it is the right place for this
conference good Lord good Lord people
have died for the freedoms we've taken
for granted for so long and that should
happen in in a city it just it just I'm
baffled I'm baffled but it it it's not
confined of course to this country let
me tell you about a man called Mark
Harding Mark Harding is a criminal Mark
Harding is a criminal he can't come to
your country he can't cross the border
because he's been convicted of a crime
now if you met Mark Harding if you met
him he a big S teddy bear of a guy
rather simple fellow really I don't say
that in a pejorative way he's he's a
lovely man but I think he would Adit a
pretty basic fellow in many ways doesn't
claim to be a great thinker a deep
intellectual thank the Lord he's just a
lovely fellow but he is also a criminal
and he cannot travel across the border
what did he do well some years ago some
years ago he decided that he would hand
out some leaflets close to a Muslim
School outlining the way Christians and
other minorities are treated in the
Islamic world this is not a point of
debate it's not a fantasy it's not a
myth as we speak as I speak to you now
another Christian is being beaten raped
murdered for being a Christian in the
Islamic
world it's a fact it's an open wound
festering and he handed out these
leaflets there was no foul language no
pornography no naked women no insults
just listing some of the awful things
that have been done to
Christians in the Islamic Heartland and
the Islamic
Homeland he was charged with a hate
crime he is so far the only man in
Ontario to be convicted of a hate crime
he was found guilty of having an
opinion his sentence was to perform
community service in the local is
Islamic community center which he said I
will do with great love and pleasure he
said I will happily clean the toilets I
will happily clean the toilets for other
people made in the image of God and they
said no no no no no no you won't you
will sit down and three Muslim leaders
will lecture you about the truth of
Islam and if you object to what they say
if you argue with them about what they
say you will have
broken the sentence regulations and you
will go to
prison in other words a man who dared to
tell the truth about the persecution of
Christians in Pakistan and Sudan and
Egypt and Gaza was told you will now
listen to an indoctrination session
about Islam and if you object we put you
in jail with the Thugs and the rapists
and the murderers
he was on my show and he's not an overly
emotional
man he sat there and I said how you
doing now and he
said not bad but and then he broke down
and he said I had a heart
attack the stress I had a heart attack
he
said uh and I take 40 different tablets
a day to keep me alive but I'm okay and
then he recovered his dignity not that
he'd ever lost it and just looked at the
camera
that's happening in
Canada let me tell you about a a public
school we have no separation of church
and state as you have here but
effectively we do and we have a a public
education system schools where if you if
you dare to talk about Christianity
believe me you're be in big trouble
they've just voted to ban Gideon Bibles
from a school system because after all
if any child is given a Gideon Bible
well come we know all hell break loose
so that can't be done but in this public
school funded by the public they've
decided that one day a week it's mosque
time and the cafeteria classes disrupted
so the cafeteria is turned into a mosque
where boys and girls are separated and
at the very back it's the young women
who are menstruating because they
obviously are filthy and they can't be
anywhere near even the girls are in the
second row so they're way at the back
all on Public Funding simultaneously if
you dare to mention Christianity in one
of these schools you'll be sent home
with a very angry note to your
parent you probably heard of Ezra
lant you heard of Ezra
lant I'd like to say he was a great man
but I I know him too well no he's a
great man and he also has a show on Sun
News and I I know most of you can't get
Sun News in the United States but please
watch on the various uh blogs and and
websites and on YouTube because we will
we won't hold back until they drag us
off screaming and kicking and boy we
will kill can scream and fight and bite
and pinch and
whatever we'll carry on speaking the
truth Ezra was charged under a blasphemy
law now they didn't call it that because
even they are not quite that stupid Ezra
Ezra is a wonderful guy who uh survives
it seems to me and I work next to him on
a diet of Red Bull and um and Red Bull
he uh he had a small magazine in western
Canada and he decided that unlike
everyone else pretty much in media he
would would print the cartoons of
Muhammad by Kurt vestard by the way I've
had the pleasure of interviewing Kurt
vestard and spending time with him Kurt
vestard the Danish cartoonist he's an
Anar he's really a left-wing Anarchist
he's made more fun of Christianity over
the years than he ever did of Islam of
course and the cartoon he drew of
Muhammad was really quite innocuous but
even if it wasn't tough tough luck if it
wasn't what's the cartoon meant to be
it's meant to be a cartoon okay so the
media of course would not print the
cartoon the great the great New York
Times we know about the great New York
Times I'm we're not going to run the
cartoon because we feel we have the
literary ability to depict the cartoon
in our words terrific but then when you
wrote about when you wrote about a
picture of the Virgin Mary covered in
excrement at that point suddenly you
couldn't describe it in words and you
had to run the picture what happened to
their journalistic ability so the
cowards at the New York Times who were
too physically frightened to run the
cartoon and this happened everywhere we
have a So-Cal conservative newspaper
that was about to run the cartoon in
Canada they took a security costing and
they concluded it wasn't worth the money
it would have cost too much money to
make the building safe we now decide
morality and journalistic integrity on
how much it'll cost to keep your staff
safe from violence and threats but Ezra
said nope I'm going to run the cartoon
he ran the cartoon got in real trouble
and then he and then it got even worse
he went on radio in Calgary Alberta to
argue with a local Islamic leader both
on radio together and they argued about
Islam end of the interview end of the
session the Islamic leader went to the
police and said I want this man charged
he said nasty things about Islam and the
police said uh I'm afraid we don't do
that in
Canada uh yet I'm afraid we don't do
that in Canada so he went to the local
Human Rights Commission and he and I've
seen it he scribbled on a piece of paper
just scribbled on a piece of paper and
the human commission said we'll take
that case and they prosecuted Ezra and
they wouldn't let it go and it went on
for years and cost huge amounts of money
the man who brought the prosecution
never had to even turn up for any
session and for him Ezra was given no
legal representation but being Ezra and
surviving on Red Bull and Red Bull he
said I'm not going to give in and he
fought the case and he fought the case
and he had a camera set up and he sat
there with his human rights commissioner
and he said to her you are a thug your
employers are thugs you're a bully
you're a fascist and I'm not going to
back down and God bless him for that and
he won and he
won
so so we are fighting back but let me
talk about the specific oh I I have to
say this do you get little mosque on the
Prairie in the US do you get that show
you
do because it's made by something called
the
CBC men used to run away to C now they
run away to the CBC the C CBC is our
publicly funded broadcaster that seems
intent on doing all it can to destroy
Christianity and and decency and
Civility and where the director we're
the anti- CBC we're the alternative you
know it's like if you're terribly ill
you take us you get
better but the CBC has given us an
alleged comedy show it's not funny
called little mosque on the Prairie
where the the Imam is this very
good-looking hip
guy and all the Muslims are fun and
lovable the clever ones are the white
ones the less clever ones are the black
ones little bit of implicit racism in
there you know but the really stupid
people are the Christians who just go
around either being ignorant or bigoted
and they've sold this show all over the
world it's a very typical mosque in
Canada yeah so we have that to fight
I've yet to see the episode where where
the youngest daughter is
slaughtered and where another wife is
brought in because the first wife's
getting a bit too unattractive and can't
give the the man a child I've never seen
the the episode where they sponsor
International terrorism but I I'm I'm I
am assured I'm guaranteed that in the uh
the Blu-ray DVD Edition it's on the
special
features let
me let me tell you
about about
how white liberal guilt has terrible
consequences this has made profoundly
clear clear in Canada forgive me if I
read this during the 3-month trial of
Muhammad shafia his wife tuaha and their
son Hamad they were convicted thank God
thank God they were
convicted of the first-degree murder of
Zab who was 19 Sahar 17 and giti shafia
who was
13 and 50-year-old Rona Amir the three
teens were Muhammad Shafi and tua's
daughters Hamed sisters Runa was
Muhammad shaffir's first wife the four
women had been drowned in their car in
June
2009 listen to this The Killers had
chosen a canal in Kingston Kingston a
University Town halfway between Toronto
and Montreal because they assumed that
the local police would be less
sophisticated and able than those in a
larger City this is how deep and plan
the evil is they' also researched murder
techniques on the internet and planned
the onor killing the Islamic honor
killing long in
advance now the case really shook the
country
but it was only the most recent of a
dozen murders in the last 12 years and
Canada only has 32 33 million people the
most recent of a dozen murders in the
last 12 years that's one a year almost
all involving Muslim Patriarchs aided by
sons cousins and wives how could they
killing young girls who wanted to be
horribly Western by by wearing nice
clothes dating nice boys doing nice
things Often by the way dating Muslim
boys what they were dating Muslim boys
just not the right boys that the these
these killers wanted in the shafir
episode the three daughters had refused
to wear the burka and one of them had
even dared to wear a bikini good Lord
Rona Amir had been able to give her
husband children so he had taken a
second wife even though polygamy is
illegal in Canada it goes on believe me
there are numerous polygamists
weddings marriages that take place the
authorities know about it and they
refuse to
intervene although not the girl's
biological mother Rona had loved them
and tried to protect them and so she had
to die as
well there's a greater Point here
there's a greater Point here with more
long-term consequences than this one
single repugnant case the authorities
this is very important the authorities
be they police politicians social
workers social workers media are
obsessed with appearing to be
Progressive and and non nonjudgmental
where Islam is concerned partly out of a
fear of being accused of islamophobia
but also because and I think this has to
be said because they genuinely believe
that the white Christian West has more
to learn from Islam than the contary I
really believe this to be true the
shafir girls had pleaded it it it it
makes You Weep they had pleaded with
their teachers for help and while some
teachers and some Frontline social
workers acknowledged the situ the
situation was potentially disastrous the
concerns evaporated they just evaporated
as soon as they reached middle
management as soon as anyone in
administration whether it was police or
education or social work found out they
said let's Let It Go let's let it go
it's their culture so Muhammad shafir
who had written of his daughters and I
will say the word forgive me May the
devil on their
graves a
father was effectively permitted to
commit mass
murder as soon as it took
place commentators cring inly reluctant
to link the crime in any way with Islam
every euphemism they could employ the M
moments after the verdict was announced
the lead detective and he did a good job
he did a good policing job but the lead
detective in the case told the police
quote domestic violence is a terrible
thing well it is but this wasn't
domestic violence and we've just had I
mentioned to you little MOS on the
Prairie we've just had the lead actor
from Little mosque on the Prairie who's
married to the the number two at English
language CBC how the circles form
a who's on a radio ad saying as the man
who plays the good-looking Imam in
little musk on the Prairie domestic
violence is
wrong we know that that's why it's a
legal in the Western World this was an
honor killing it's different we have
never approved of demestic violence you
enshrine it in your legal system in the
Islamic
world
it was yet another example of a
psychosis that has as at its epicenter
Pakistan but it stends to most parts of
the Islamic Heartland and many in the
Muslim
diaspora look it's a self-evident truth
that not all M Muslims behave like this
but it's also self-evident truth that
more than 90% of people who do behave
like this are Muslim it's like this
nonsense about terrorism oh you say all
Muslims are terrorists no I've never
said such a thing but I do say the vast
majority invariably the bulk of
terrorism is committed by Muslims in the
name of Islam I'm not saying that they
are maybe it will be a basic courtesy
for me to believe
them they're empowered by quranic
teaching by Sharia law they're not doing
something in spite of their faith when a
Christian commits a crime it's in spite
of Christian teaching when a Jew commits
a crime it's in spite of Jewish teaching
I'm sorry when Muslims commit honor
killing it's not in spite of it's
because of Islamic
teaching when when 16year old
16-year-old AXA pz was murdered in
Canada in 2007 I think it
was by her Pakistani father and brother
care Canada yeah we have the version too
our own special version care
Canada told the gble that quote it's
important not to generalize
there are cases of violence across all
faiths and
cultures yeah we never said otherwise
but actually when it comes to honor
killings almost unheard of outside of
Islam and the small number that have
occurred in Hinduism and Sikhism are
isolated and universally condemned
within those cultures when I see the
mass ranks of Canadian Muslims marching
along the streets of Toronto and
Montreal saying no to honor killings I
may think
again it won't happen don't hold your
breath
look it's not just about honor killing
the country I'm from Britain we now have
a whole plague
of of rape gangs gangs of young Muslim
men throughout the country one even in
Oxford recently such a a quiet beautiful
place where young women young white
women are groomed raped drugged and
turned into prostitutes over and over
and over again even conservative tblo
like the Daily Mail will print the
pictures of the men they're all of
Pakistani origin or 99% of them with
their names but they won't say the magic
word Muslim they can't say the word now
if it happens to be a Norwegian mass
murderer who's a Freemason who says in
his Manifesto I have no relationship
with Christ I haven't been to church in
17 years uh I actually support abortion
rights and gay
marriage but you'll call him a Christian
as soon as you can and you'll continue
to call him a Christian as time goes on
on even though he's far from being one
but if someone commits an honor killing
or an act of Terror and says I did it in
the name of Islam because I'm a Muslim
you will still find a way to say it's
the fault of the
Jews I don't know what's going to happen
in Canada we have a heroic fight back we
have people like I mentioned Ezra leant
and Mark Stein who you probably know of
here as well but he's one of
ours we have a government a sort of
conservative government that is very
good on this issue and a wonderful
immigration Minister Jason Kenny who is
prepared to say no to extremism we have
a we have a Prime Minister Steven Harper
who was the first person to say no no no
to Hamas long before the Americans got
into it we said no to Hamas as soon as
they won we're not backing you anymore
we're taking all the money away
so so there is great hope but the
problem is among so many people the mass
indifference engineered by media
everyone is the same
relativism fundamentalism is the problem
here not the particular religion well
the next time a fundamentalist Quaker or
a fundamentalist Catholic or a
fundamentalist Unitarian tries to cut my
head off or blow my plane up I'll start
to believe them until then just shut up
it's a real pleasure and honor to be
here and to meet people I mean I've
never met Pam she Pam's been on my show
many times never actually met her now
I've met her Robert I have met before
but other people I've never met before
that the work you're doing really is
extraordinary and I I want to end with
an anecdote and and I don't use this in
anybody to be exclusive I have I'm a
Catholic I mean if you're not that's
your problem but I'm a Catholic
I'll pray for
you but I won't threaten to cut your
head
off but one of the great influences
Inspirations in my life has been a man
called Thomas Moore he he he's a
saint he was he was Prime Minister of
England he was called Chancellor but he
was Prime Minister of England he was one
of the great public intellectuals
brilliant known throughout the world and
he had everything really and then King
Henry VII decided he wanted to take a
different
wife and that was really the issue
wasn't actually the Reformation it was
just about marriage and Thomas Moore
said you can't do this your majesty
you're already married and anyway they
fell out and mo was arrested he lost
everything he he lost all his money his
power his family weren't allowed to see
him he knew he was going to die and he
was interrogated he wasn't physically
tortured but he was interrogated night
after night after night and the last
interrogation before he was executed
before they did cut off his
head he was taken from the Tower of
London to Lambeth Palace and and he sat
there thin bearded by this point point
and in front of him was the new prime
minister Thomas Cromwell the Duke of
norol the most powerful Aristocrat in
the country the Archbishop of
canterburry when that really meant
something and they sat there and they
hared him more than an
hour and he just wouldn't say anything
just wouldn't say anything and at the
end as they were packing up the dukee of
Norfolk said to him oh for goodness sake
he said this is pride this is pride he
said because look we're in the majority
look Thomas we're in the majority and
for the first time Thomas Moore his eyes
opened up there was a new Clarity in
them he looked up and he gazed right at
them and he said well he
said knowing he would die in the morning
if the Gates of Heaven if the windows of
the afterlife could open now you would
see that no no no no I'm in the
majority no matter how persecuted and
alone and isolated you may feel when you
leave here and you go back to your home
remember
remember decency goodness integrity and
morality you we are in the
majority